James Baldwin recently we sat down with
author bell hooks to find out how she
was influenced by Baldwin's life and
writings this interview was about a half
hour bell hooks when you hear the name
James Baldwin what's the first thing
that pops into your mind
incredible daring thinker
why because Baldwin thought against the
green and he covered a lot of territory
I think it many people don't realize
that because they typecast him as either
a gay writer or they don't read the
range of his work this is a man who was
you know a novelist and essayist in many
ways a cultural critic before we had the
term for example his book on film lots
of people don't even know that Baldwin
wrote a book on film so he was doing
really what we now today call a cultural
critic covering a wide range of topics
writing some social theory essays but
really looking at culture and how
culture shapes people particularly
looking at race and sexuality within
culture let's break apart what you said
then first take the thinker part what
was the what was his focus as a thinker
and what was his strength as a thinker a
primary focus for Baldwin as a thinker
was what makes us human what makes us
able to tap into essential goodness he
thought against the notion that we are
born to dominate so he was interested in
how does that basic essential goodness
get perverted by racism by homophobia by
anything and how do we how do we restore
our sense of well-being you know when he
has that letter to his nephew where he's
saying you know you're born black into a
world that expects nothing of you so you
have to expect excellence of yourself
and that was the quintessential Baldwin
that call for excellence that called to
push against the boundaries and to be
willing to do
whatever it took to get where you needed
to go what did the period of time that
he wrote how did that influence what he
wrote and how he wrote I think it was
one of the most exciting periods in our
nation's history I often think if I was
imagining a time in which I should have
been born because my to literary mentor
figures in my life were of that period
Lorraine Hansberry and James Baldwin and
in you know the opening to the book
young gifted and black its Baldwin that
she first evokes as part of her her last
statements before her very early death
in her 30s is her relationship with him
and his sort of challenging her to to
make those leaps and thought and action
I mean here were people that were
political they were very concerned with
colonisation in Africa that he was so
concerned with what was happening in
Harlem and with the fate of Harlem all
of those things taking place before our
culture had really come to grips with
racial segregation so that they were
really the avant-garde I think of James
Baldwin as leading that avant-garde
thinking that was challenging a lot of
what we take for granted today you know
we take for granted certain challenges
to racism or to sexuality they're just a
part of what many people feel is the
accepted way to live now they were there
when they were on the edge Lorraine
Hansberry James Baldwin but particularly
Baldwin because he did live so much
longer than Lorraine Hansberry and he
lived to see shifts and changes in a way
that few scholars thinkers - and he
lived to write about those changes and
to also let us know what didn't change
what he felt wasn't changing enough set
the scene for us in his early writing
and what it was like for him to go up
against the ideas that were so pervasive
at the time well when we talk about
setting the scene
we have to talk about first and foremost
a scene of you know that is urban that
is New York City that is people trying
to be hip and cool because again think
about those words we use them with
complete nonchalance but in those days
those were loaded words hip cool you
know it was really almost like saying
you were a communist or I mean cuz to
say that you were trying to be bohemian
you were trying to be hip and cool was
to already be placing yourself outside
the mainstream you know to live in the
village the West Village that I live in
now which was the place where Baldwin
and others came to be transgressive I
mean the world of the West Village I
live in now is so calm and complacent
but that worl was a world where black
people and white people were getting
together men were getting together to be
sexual with men people were being
bisexual a whole world was happening
then that was a subculture a true and
genuine subculture and Baldwin was a
part of that how did his writings
reflect that then well we started with
Giovanni's Room we see him dealing in
that first book you know what black
writer before him had openly taken on
the issues of gayness the fact that
there isn't any real sense of racial
identity in Giovanni's room so he's
challenging that whole idea of what is
acceptable for a black writer to write
and think about it's all there in
Giovanni's Room now I have to tell you
that I am NOT a fan of Baldwin's fiction
I am truly much more fan of essays I
love essays of course I am also a writer
of essays and fiction is not as crucial
to me so the Baldwin that I kind of
worship is the Baldwin that is dealing
with analyzing the culture we live in
the conversation list the conversation
with Margaret Mead Audrey Lorde he was a
consummate conversationalist and I tell
people all the time that learning takes
place more than in schools more than
through reading people learn through
conversation to what they're sharing
with others in the day leanness of life
and so everyone who knew Baldwin talked
about how he was constantly talking
he was constantly engaging you
challenging you forcing you to think and
I think seeing him as a literary mentor
in a sense I've patterned a lot of my
own essay writing my cultural critic
also a critic around that provocative
sense of make people think and that's
what he did he made people think did he
know he was doing that at the time oh I
think he was totally you know in the
sort of best spirit of what it means to
be a queen as a gay man what if that is
to to to it excite an insight and he
knew that he was doing both that he was
inciting people to disagreement to to
challenge and he was very much an agent
provocateur and he enjoyed that role he
enjoyed throwing the idea in that was
going to upset everyone that was going
to make everyone feel what are you
talking about
and that was very much a chosen role for
Baldwin what was the reaction of people
and readers as his writing started to
canal well there were you know a lot of
different reactions because on one hand
the again he was celebrated by the
dissident thinking world that said ah
here is a intellectual black man because
I think of Baldwin as an organic
intellectual what do you mean by that
but that is to say he didn't get PhDs he
didn't go to universities and and study
in in in the way that the contemporary
intellectuals were talking about because
much more than say a Cornel West today
Baldwin was truly a public intellectual
because he came to be known through his
activism for different causes within a
public setting and he was a thinking
reflecting person but not in the
university world not in the the sense of
being taught and schooled in having a
PhD writing a dissertation but when I
say organic
is the schooling of himself the teaching
of himself his travels to other cultures
I mean I think for example of his
traveling to Europe and writing you know
those profound words that so many
cultural critics of race used today the
world is white no longer and it will
never be white again I mean this was
Baldwin cracking open the whole
relationship between imperialism work
and immigration that would change the
nature of Europe I mean I tell people
today we see all these movies where
England is white but in fact whenever
I'm in London and other places I'm
astounded by the incredible cultural
diversity there's never anywhere where
you are or you're not seeing it and
Baldwin was prescient that is prophetic
in that he foresaw this is the way the
world was going did his what was more
prevalent for him his blackness or his
homosexuality well I think what he would
say is neither of those things it was
his humanity it was the idea that we are
always more than our pain were always
more than whatever socially constructed
identity is posed upon us and that was
his great I said would say sadness an
anguish of spirit that in many ways by
identifying with causes whether of race
or sexuality one risk that people would
lose sight of your overall humanity that
here was a man who was very interested
in aesthetics and style and yet often
when people saw him they solely saw him
as a spokesperson of race or later on as
both the person of sexuality and you
know one of the later interviews of
before his death with Glenn O'Brien he's
actually talking against just that kind
of narrow sense of what it is to be an
african-american person in the world
that we want to have our full humanity
that we don't don't want to focus solely
on race and that's what he felt Europe
offered him the place where he could
forget race as the predominating factor
of his existence you know that he could
go there and people might want to know
what do you think of you know
agriculture in you know such in such a
place where as here so often especially
in his day and and one only was allowed
to speak about race not to speak about
all the other issues of your that might
you know challenge and excite your
imagination has that changed I think it
has changed tremendously and it has
changed more in the world of what we can
teach speak and write about then in the
world of publishing I think Baldwin was
would be shaking his said head sadly
knowing that it's still difficult for
black writers to do nonfiction work to
do nonfiction that is taken seriously
that is not journalism because I think
that sure we have the world of
journalism has opened up so wide I mean
we have black journalists of all
different perspectives conservative
progressive writing when we come to
nonfiction books particularly books that
are not minhwa or biography we're
struggling still struggling to have that
space were african-american thinkers can
say whatever they want to say and take
on the topics that they wanted to take
on you know Baldwin was someone for
example who wrote a lot about love he
was very interested in the question of
love and yet in his time and in his day
he probably could not have written a
book on love that would have received a
great deal of attention because I think
in his day people would have said well
what is this
you know homosexual black man from
Harlem have to teach us about love how
did his his thoughts on love impact your
three books on completely and utterly I
mean when he talks about the whole idea
of he says that if you can't suffer you
can't grow up or you know my favorite
Baldwin quote that I'm telling people
all the time
hate he defined and sentimentality and
this is Baldwin and his most queenly and
lavish sentimentality Baldwin says
is the ostentatious parading of
excessive and spurious emotion it's the
mark of dishonesty the inability to feel
and that's Baldwin saying that if we
want to do the work of love we've got to
get past shallow sentiment we've got to
be willing to do the hard work and he
does it in his writing he does it to
illuminate you know what does love
really mean he tried to elevate the
relationships between gay men past the
sexual and to really get to that place
of the emotions of how can people be
humanized in the act of loving how can
be people be transformed through erotic
and romantic connection and that's a
very different Baldwin from the early
Baldwin writing about race it's the
balding Baldwin of of longing of
yearning for his own space of love and
wholeness and I took all of that as
something that inspired me in writing
salvation black people and love he's
there from the very beginning because he
was one of the the thinkers who really
put that on the table are black people
going to allow themselves to be so
dehumanized by the impact of racism and
other forms of domination that we're
going to miss out on love he raised that
question again and again and again
calling us to always protect our
essential humanity our essential
goodness what was the reaction in the
gay community at the time to his
writings I don't think Baldwin had a
huge audience in the gay community
because we have to remember that Baldwin
liked his white male contemporaries was
really a part of a kind of elite
literati he wasn't even so much being
read by you know middle-class black
people of gay or straight it was very
much about this particular New York City
based group of thinkers who thought they
were you know the sort of thinkers of
our time the avant-garde thinkers that
we're going to sort of give us a new way
to think and live but in fact they had
very little impact
on masses of people for example
Baldwin's fiction had a much wider
readership than the essay said were in
fact so provocative so so prophetic
around race those things were primarily
read by the the elite classes of people
who were thinking about race and
sexuality and gender because he also had
a lot to say about gender and and
challenging the the sort of standard
ginger roles you might say he is one of
our first really contemporary black male
advocates of feminism because he
certainly advocated for a shift in black
male roles I mean he advocated a
critique of religion which I think black
communities in America have yet to live
up to that he was both deeply religious
deeply spiritual but constantly
cognizant of the evils of religion when
it's used in a fascist way to discipline
and punish people and to rob them of
their self-worth and he really wrote a
lot about that when he was writing do
you do you know you mentioned that he
wrote was writing essays both and the
fiction and you preferred the essays
were at least that was where you liked
you enjoyed it most do you know what
kind of questions he went in and out of
in making the determination on whether
to write fiction or whether to write
essays well I think like most of his
contemporaries he was a very you know
market driven writer because we have to
remember that Baldwin once again not
like myself or other people today black
cultural critics who were housed in the
university getting salaries he was many
times trying to make his living as a
writer and it was that force that often
led him you know to cut deals and begin
writing things and be incomplete or in
in writing something I mean you know I
think you can contrast him with someone
like Truman Capote where you see that
same kind of both writing at times very
seriously but at other times writing in
the direction of the marketplace when
did you when do you first remember
reading
James Baldwin I first remember reading
James Baldwin when my working-class
father would come home from his his work
as a janitor at the post office and he
would open the glass bookcase that was
his special bookcase and in that book
case were the cheap paperback books of
James Baldwin the fire next time and I
remember you know you know reading that
little statement God gave Noah the
rainbow signed no more water the fire
next time and that was my reading of
Baldwin and I remember that thin
newsprint paper that was so compelling
to me you know and because we remember
I'm I'm in my teens I mean when I say
teens I mean early teens 12 and 13 and
I'm reading James Baldwin and I'm trying
to connect James Baldwin to my Stern
conservative patriarchal father they
couldn't have been more different but
there he was in the bookcase and
therefore to be valued and learned about
did you and talk to your father ever
about James Baldwin absolutely not
because in fact I used to have to sneak
into that bookcase on how the two get
books and read them because my parents
did not feel that they were
age-appropriate what is it about the
style of James Baldwin first of all what
is the style and hen as a literary
mentor have you also taken on or looked
at his style in terms of influencing you
one of the best aspects of Baldwin's
essay style particularly was its clarity
and in fact it's so funny because you
can contrast that with the over
wordiness and novels like go tell it on
the mountain and that the essays were
clear they were concise they had a
crispness and I think I have definitely
tried to have that readability but that
that Crispus that you don't let let
anything go you don't leave anything out
but you make it something that can be
read by people and you use language in a
way that is is enjoyable and so that you
can read Baldwin aloud and you can see
how he is putting those words together
to enchant us I mean when he he that
goes on and on about the idea of
suffering and growing up and he puts it
together in a way that's magical
you have I've read in an interview that
youth self criticized yourself saying
that your sentences are too long
what were Bolden's like Baldwin
sentences were much shorter partially
because he came out of the world of
journalism and you know as in fact part
of how I trained myself to shorten my
sentences was to begin to write for
magazines and newspapers because the
kind of long sentences that I had been
encouraged to use in the academic world
have no place in the world of of
journalism and and magazine writing so I
think he honed that craft and that skill
in that world of being told you've got
200 words and you got to say it and
you've got to figure out a way to say it
with with meaning and substance and he
was really great at doing that how did
he influence the civil rights movement
he was constantly there as a force
mediating between the conservative
factors and the more radical factors I
mean he was you know enchanted by you
know both Martin Luther King and Malcolm
X and and and yet he understood the
place of militant rethinking because in
a sense part of what made Malcolm X
different from Martin Luther King is
Malcolm X was calling on us to really
rethink our perceptions of ourselves
King wrote very little about how black
people should feel about themselves much
of his his writing was outer directed it
was directed at what should we do in
relationship to white people
I think Baldwin was kind of in adoration
of Malcolm because Malcolm was so much
concerned with what should we do in
relation to ourselves and you see
Baldwin's real concern for his his
nieces and nephews his family
that autobiographical writing or he is
concern in a concrete and practical way
how can we save the lives of these black
children and other poor black children
how can we make it possible for them to
educate themselves you know he had this
phrase he used all the time don't make
peace with mediocrity and I think that
we we need to listen to that phrase
today because there's a lot of writing
happening there's a lot of sloppy
thinking happening that is you know
reproducing the mediocre if he could see
today you mentioned the writing the
publishing world he wouldn't be too keen
on but what about life in general in
terms of race relations I think that he
would really just grieve that you know
you know in a sense so much of the
thinking about race today is less
sophisticated than it was then because
the real vision that everyone had was of
the loved community it was of ending
racism and we're living in a time where
people are very cynical about the
possibility of ending racism or creating
community and that Europe that he loved
and that he thought as a haven has
changed so completely so that it's not
the sanctuary for the person of color
fleeing the United States that it once
was because of you know immigration and
how and work so that I think he would be
son by the Europe of today you know
because the Europe of the day today has
become more like the United States was
back then the world that he was fleeing
so I think he would be in a state of
grief as you as you go through your life
with him as your literary mentor and
study him talk about in my presume in
your classes absolutely I teach a whole
seminar on James Baldwin what is the one
thing that is not brought up in the
books about him in the histories about
him what don't we know about James
Baldwin or what isn't talked about
enough in your opinion I think it's not
talked about enough that he was
concerned so much with the well-being
of black family life because I think
that people have such a tendency the
moment they hear that a writer is gay to
assume that in fact they're not
interested in families and by that I
mean nuclear families families
interaction between fathers and sons and
mothers and sons and all of these things
were tremendous issues for him he tried
hard to be a parenting figure for his
nieces and nephews and I think that we
don't talk enough about the gay men and
women in our culture who in fact are
there as those enlightened witnesses
that a psychoanalyst Alice Miller talks
about that every child should have a
kind of guardian angel that is not so
much in the primary family structure but
that is a sort of outside observer who
can come in and help rescue and
transform and he was that he was deeply
deeply concerned about the stability of
the black family in our times and I
think he would be deeply grieved at what
has happened to black family life in the
United States is there any part of him
you didn't like or you don't like well
for me you know the thing that was
really sad about Baldwin was the the
place of addiction in his life of the
drinking and the loss of of that sense
of himself as someone who had value and
worse because I think we have to
remember that his own woundedness at the
hands of his father the the physical
beatings that he sustained the shame
around his homosexuality those things
were never healed and alcohol was very
much that force that that soothed that
pain and so that was something that I
felt saddened when I first began to
study Baldwin that he never had the
opportunity to drink at that well of
healing and self recovery so that that
we would know that he had made the
journey from that internalized
self-hatred to full-on self love and
self recovery that he inspires so many
of us to make
was that community or life of alcohol
part of the intellectual group that he
hung out slowly I mean one of the things
that's think about Lorraine Hansberry
she dies of lung cancer in every picture
that you see of her she's smoking a
cigarette you know that whole world of
the beats of the whole sort of literary
world of a certain period of our culture
was about drinking drugs cigarette
overeating it was about excess and
hedonism and many people were victims of
it and in fact you know we're really
lucky that Baldwin lived as long as he
did because he was definitely out there
transgressing in the life taking risk
you know being that hedonistic consumer
of fine wines and all of that you know
did he Tim packed his writing I think it
always impacts writers because it makes
you sloppy and I think that some of his
fiction was simply sloppy bell hooks
thank you very much tomorrow our
American writers series continues as we
turn our attention to Betty Ford an
author of The Feminine Mystique learn
about feminism and the women's rights
movement of the 1960s and 70s and we'll
broadcast live from Fred Anne's alma
mater Smith College in Northampton
Massachusetts that begins at 3:00